[Musique]
bill weed ton cri juste si tu
t'entraînes toi aussi tu peux être x man
x men c'est pas ma canne mais alors pas
du tout parce que tout d'abord on m'a
déjà dépuceler
je le protégerai contre câbles mais tout
seul je peux pas je suis à x mazières ta
gueule de la stout et sinon que je
crains justin bieber a tu as vu utah
prises pour justin bieber et paris
dès qu'un bouffon
déguisé en soi tellement d'arc tu es sûr
que tu viens pas l'univers dc comics
on est en approche
bref
intercepte pouvoir attention ac
aubin ces gamins et en difficulté dégage
mollo sur la haine la noce
le protégerait contre câble est tout
seul je peux pas faut du renfort
on va former un super méga groupe mais
on va refaire un tour sur linkedin
je te présente bedlam je m'appelle
shatter star domino j'ai de la chance la
chance c'est pas super pouvoir écouter
sinon
mais si on n'a qu'à couper la poire en
deux c'est non aller en piste
donc on
[Musique]
départ au vatican et qui sait en juin
tellement d'arc
tu es sûr que tu viens pas l'univers dc
comics
[Musique]
oui
dis donc t'es balles elles sont rapides
maintenant pour cours les tous peter un
super pouvoir quelconque je sais pas
nager pas de pouvoir non j'ai vu
l'annoncé voilà tel poste
[Musique]